metal ear cells are a relatively new
type of portable energy source
consisting of a metal anode an alkaline
electrolyte paste that contains water
and a porous cathode membrane that lets
in oxygen from the air a schematic of
the cell is shown above and so we see
the different parts right over here we
see the metal anode it's an anode so
this would be the negative terminal of
our power source it'll be the source of
electrons we have an alkaline
electrolyte paste that contains water
let me underline that there's a lot of
interesting words there alkaline
electrolyte paste that contains water
that's this right over here in the
middle they when they say it's alkaline
that means that it's going to be basic
versus acidic it's going to have a pH
higher than 7 electrolyte paste an
electrolyte is something that if you
dissolve it in a polar substance a polar
substance like water well then the
solution is going to be good at
conducting electricity so what they tell
us it this electrolyte paste is going to
be something that's good at conducting
electricity and they tell us it's
alkaline so it's going to be basic it's
going to have a pH higher than 7 and a
porous cathode membrane that lets in
oxygen from the air so this is the
cathode this is going to be the positive
terminal this is where the electrons are
going to be attracted to and it's porous
cathode membrane that lets in oxygen
from the air and you so you can see that
oxygen is available in this membrane it
sits so it somehow is allowed to seep in
because it is porous reduction
potentials for the cathode and three
possible metal anodes are given in the
table below
so remember reduction potentials you can
view these are reduction is is is the
gaining of electrons so this is the
potential to gain electrons is one way
to think about a reaction that somehow
involves electrons being incorporated in
some way and right over here you have
molecular oxygen reacting with water
which for every molecule of molecular
oxygen you have two molecules of water
four electrons and then they react to
form four hydroxide anions so once again
this is a reduction reaction because
those electrons are being incorporated
into
into the molecule and so you're left
with the hydroxide right over here and
if you look at our our metal Aircel up
here where is that occurring well you
need oxygen you need water and you need
electrons well if you look at the
cathode right over here you got your
electrons coming in you got your oxygen
coming in and water we can assume is
available in this area the electrolyte
paste has water in it this the cathode
is porous it's a porous membrane type
substance so they're all available over
here so you can assume that that
reaction could happen right over here in
the cathode so let me just write it o to
in as a gas plus so for every molecule
of o2 you're going to have two molecules
of h2o in a liquid form and then you got
your electrons coming in on the wire I
guess you could say and that is going to
yield four hydroxide anions for
hydroxide anions and they're in a
solution they're part of that
electrolyte paste that's in water
they're an aqueous solution a
water-based solution and so that's going
to happen right over there so the
hydroxide anions I can even say for
hydroxide anions are going to be
produced every time this reaction is
happening and they tell us the reduction
potential this has a positive potential
has a positive voltage and notice they
say the reduction potential at pH 11 so
that's consistent with a alkaline
alkaline conditions because this paste
might seep in through here a little bit
and obviously you have all this
hydroxide being produced so you're going
to have a higher pH a more basic pH and
so the fact that this is a positive
voltage so plus 0.34 volts means that
that the the potential is going in this
direction the electric potential favors
this reaction to happen going from left
to right now they also said they gave us
the reduction potentials for the cathode
which we just talked about this is the
reduction potential for the cathode and
three possible metal anodes are given in
the table below so here there are three
possible metal anodes so we're going to
zinc we could have sodium we could have
we could have calcium and so
just go with zinc since it's the first
one listed here so if we assumed that
the metal here was zinc what's going to
be going on we're going to have the zinc
reacting with these hydroxides that are
being produced over in the cathode and
then you're going to use that to produce
zinc oxide water and electrons so we're
actually going to have the reverse of
this reaction you're going to have let
me write the reverse you're going to
have zinc in the solid state
this whole animal anode is made out of
metal zinc and then for every molecule
of that you're going to have two
hydroxide anions that are dissolved in
water that's what makes the electrolyte
paste alkaline and you are going to then
go to your they're going to react and
you're going to form zinc oxide zinc
oxide in the solid state plus water in
the liquid state plus two plus two
electrons and so this reaction that I
just described this is going to be
happening right over here so you could
think of it as the hydroxide anions get
formed at the cathode and then they move
their way over to the left to the anode
where they react with the zinc and they
turn they or the zinc reacts and it
forms a zinc oxide so you have more and
more zinc oxide being formed water which
can then see if it's way back into the
electrolyte pace and then it can
eventually react again at the cathode
and then you have these two electrons so
these electrons this turns into an
electron source right over here and then
the electrons would migrate and then
they can go to the positive side the
cathode to react again and so you can
start to see how this will be an energy
source that you can tap into this
current that'll be dental form to to do
some to do some useful work that's why
you have an energy source all right so
let's read the questions now that we
have a decent understanding of what's
going on early forms of metal air cells
use zinc as the anode all as the example
we just thought about zinc oxide is
produced as the cell operates according
to the overall equation below two to
four every two molecules of zinc and one
molecule of molecular oxygen you produce
two molecules of zinc oxide
use the data in the table above
calculate the cell potential for the
zinc-air cell so let's think about let's
break down this reaction we actually we
can just break it down into into these
two steps here because notice this is
this is you can't see them both at the
same time but this the the the things
that are reacting you have zinc let me
underline the things that are reacting
you have zinc you have zinc you have
oxygen you have oxygen and so if you
return this if you return the second
reaction around like we did before and
let me rewrite it right let me rewrite
both of them actually a little bit lower
right over here so you have this top
reaction so you have o to gaseous state
plus 2 h2o liquid plus 4 electrons oops
4 electrons yields 4 hydroxide anions
and aqueous solution and then this one
we said we're going to go in the other
direction so you're going to have zinc
you're going to have zinc in the solid
state plus 2 hydroxide anions and then
that's going to yield zinc zinc oxide in
the solid state plus liquid water plus 2
electrons so when you see this you see
that we are reacting we have the oxygen
we have the zinc which are the two
things we were on interact here and if
you want to make them equivalent in
terms of the number of molecules we
could say alright with one molecule of
molecular oxygen and we need to zinc's
so let me multiply this whole this whole
reaction by 2 so it's 2 zinc's react
with 4 hydroxides react to produce two
zinc oxides 4 oh sorry 2 molecules of
water 2 molecules of water and then 4
electrons I just said oh if this
reaction happened twice you would have
just twice as many of the reactants and
and the products here and then notice
now you have a molecule of molecular
oxygen 2 molecules
of zinc molecule of molecular oxygen two
molecules of zinc if all of this were to
happen you are going to produce two
molecules of zinc oxide and what about
everything else that I that I put that
we're in these reactions well the water
is here but then water also gets two
molecules of water two molecules of
water so it's I guess if you look at the
total reaction we're neutral there we
haven't produced or lost any water you
have four electrons you have four
electrons so that's why they didn't
write it in this total reaction here and
these four hydroxide molecules iron ions
well they're going to be used up in this
second part of the reaction so we're in
neutral there they get produced but then
they get used so if you look at the
total reaction you're using the
molecular oxygen and the zinc to produce
zinc oxide and so they say use the data
in the table above calculate the cell
potential for the zinc air cell well the
potential for this top reaction is zero
is positive 0.34 volts and now what's
the reaction what's the potential for
this bottom reaction well it's the
reverse of this reaction so this
reaction had this reaction has a
negative potential but since we reverse
it it's going to be a positive potential
so it's going to be positive 1.3 1 volts
now some of you might be saying well not
only did we reverse it we multiplied it
by two we said two of those reactions
when we multiplied the voltage by two
well if we were just thinking about the
energy released from a reaction well
they absolutely if you're gonna have the
reaction twice or twice as much of the
reaction you're gonna have twice as much
of the energy but voltage you have to
remember that's you can view it as
potential energy per unit charge so
since we're not this isn't kind of your
absolute energy this is your energy per
unit charge is one way to think about it
when you're doing it more of it it
doesn't change the actual voltage so
that's an important thing thing to think
about if this was talking about total
energy or enthalpy or something like
that then if you're if you were to
multiply both sides by two you would
multiply the energy released or taken by
two but since we're talking about
voltage voltage isn't a quantity that
depends on the number of charges or the
number of molecules you're doing - it's
a per its what is the potential per unit
charge is one way to think about it and
so for this whole reaction we would just
add the combined voltage of both of
these and then you would get one point
six five one point six five volts now
let's do part two the electrolyte paste
contains hydroxide and hydroxide ions on
the diagram of the cell above draw an
arrow to indicate the direction of
migration of hydroxide ions through the
electrolyte as a cell operates well
we've already thought about that the
hydroxide gets produced at the cathode
with this reaction and then it gets used
up in the anode so the hydroxide is
going to be moving the hydroxide is
going to be moving in that direction